ladies and gentlemen
the race
is about to begin
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hello everyone
i'm augustana davita producer on
trackmania at ubisoft nadio
to the excitement of its 10 million fans
trackmania is back on consoles and
streaming platforms early 203
and the first bit of good news is that
cosplay and cross progression will be
available across all platforms
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series stadia and
luna
trackmania is free to play with no
microtransaction but we do offer two
premium assets that unlock even more
social and community features you will
still experience that same adrenaline in
rush on extraordinary tracks be solo or
online with hundreds of live opponents
we have lots of features to keep you
racing there's a new seasonal official
campaign every three months
esports events like the cup of the day
with thousands of players the track of
the day which highlights our players
creativity
and you can team up with your friends to
play in the royal or ranked game mods
and that's not all
crackmania is the best place for
creators to unlock their full
imagination with its industry-leading
and powerful track editor featuring
thousands of blocks and items
after its pc launch two years ago the
game is stronger than ever with 280
thousand tracks created by players
worldwide
the great news is that these tracks will
be available from day one on the console
and cloud versions
with trackmania clubs we are offering
deep social features within the game
with skin customization private rooms as
well as campaigns and competitions
organized by the players for the players
we're looking forward to reuniting the
complete trackmania community in one
single world no matter where and all you
play starting early 2023 welcome to the
club
i'll